fake gurus where should we draw the line
on one side we have tons of shady
business gurus pumping all sorts of
crypto schemes drop shipping strategies
and online courses and on the other side
we have massively successful
billionaires who are endlessly
worshipped online but we never really
talk about the middle what about the
people that give out some advice but
aren't at that world famous level yet
how can we separate the good from the
bad and where do finance youtubers like
graham steffen fit in well to answer
this we need to develop some rules that
we can use to assess the value of a
particular business guru fortunately
it's pretty easy to look back and see
who's been making good calls for years
and who's clearly just been riding
trends and cashing in so our first
filter should just be the quality of the
advice given out by a particular person
one of the biggest problems with fake
gurus is that they tend to lead you
astray they'll tell you to invest at the
worst possible times and then quickly
move on to the next trendy investment as
soon as the last one collapses in fact
watching fake gurus pump a particular
asset can actually be a good indicator
that things are about to crash that's
what happened in 1929 right before the
great depression joseph kennedy who was
the father of jfk was a prominent
businessman and investor at the time the
economy was booming throughout the 1920s
and it looked like everything just
wouldn't stop going up in value but then
a friend told kennedy that he noticed
something very odd happening taxi
drivers had started giving him stock
tips and his shoeshine boy could give
him a complete summary of the day's
financial news as he worked with the rag
and polish even the homeless man on the
street in front of his office wanted to
talk about the market kennedy took this
warning and sold his entire stock
portfolio and began shorting the market
the bet paid off big time and the
shoeshine boy has been a metaphor for
market bubbles ever since during a big
market boom everyone looks like a genius
since everything is constantly going up
in value but after the market crashes it
becomes clear who's real and who's fake
and i personally experienced this in
2009 i picked up a book on real estate
investing by an author named robert
kiyosaki it seemed to have some useful
information in it and it was a nice
change of pace from the economics
textbooks i'd been reading in college
but something seemed off about it see
the book was published before the
housing bubble collapsed and all of the
assumptions in the book were based on
the outdated expectation that housing
prices would never go down in hindsight
the strategy he outlined looked a lot
more risky than he made it sound and
that ultimately led him to being labeled
a fake guru online and eventually even
filing for bankruptcy in 2012. so rule
number one seems ironclad right when we
see a guru type hyping an investment we
just need to check their track record
and we'll easily be able to tell if
they're the real deal or not right well
it's not quite so simple see sometimes
people make legitimate mistakes but are
still well intentioned this happens for
a few reasons sometimes people just get
ahead of themselves like when bill gates
published a memo in 1995 about the
internet title wave that was around the
corner his message was crystal clear the
internet was about to change everything
and he was laughed at on late night tv
for making such aggressive claims but
here's the weird thing bill gates was
wrong in the short term but right in the
long term the first internet title wave
caused tons of investors to wipe out
during the dot-com crash but anyone who
built for the long term wound up sailing
off into the sunset so if it was 2001
and you were watching your portfolio of
internet stocks crash you'd probably be
pretty justified in calling bill gates a
fake guru but then you'd be proven wrong
over the next decade so we can't purely
look at recent track records to
determine if someone is the real deal or
not we have to go deeper well maybe we
should follow the money it's always a
little suspicious when you see someone
asking people to pay for information
these days especially considering how
much information is widely available for
free online and nearly everyone who gets
called a fake guru regularly has some
sort of paid online course that they are
constantly shilling to their followers
drop shipping crypto trading life
coaching and more are all ripe targets
for paid courses and i've even seen
people selling courses about selling
courses it's extremely meta but i guess
when you've run out of things to teach
people the best option is to just teach
them about teaching these paid products
sit at the core of every fake guru
accusation most people wouldn't care if
these gurus were just shouting into the
void on social media the problem always
comes when they convince people to
overextend themselves and go into debt
to pay for some expensive course or
seminar that simply doesn't provide the
value they promise so this feels like a
simple rule we can apply across the
board if you're charging people money
for information you're probably a fake
guru and should be avoided but a blanket
statement like this doesn't quite work
out in practice for a few reasons just
look at all the counter examples first
let's look at the billionaire author of
shoe dog phil knight co-founded nike and
spent decades building it into a massive
global athletic brand there's no doubt
that he's the real deal when it comes to
business he's worth tens of billions of
dollars and anyone can independently
verify his accomplishments in a matter
of minutes he's basically the opposite
of a fake guru but then why doesn't he
give his memoir away for free the book
is an international bestseller it's
clearly helped millions of people deepen
their understanding of business and it's
even being adapted into a netflix biopic
phil clearly doesn't need the money from
the book sales so why not let the
information be free well publishing a
physical book does have a real cost as
does distributing it to bookstores
across the world i'm sure dozens of
people helped him edit the story
translate the book into different
languages and design the cover art all
of those people should be paid and 14.99
is a reasonable price to ask people to
pay for such an entertaining book
clearly the value a reader gets from
shoe dog is greater than 15 bucks so
instead of getting called a fake guru
phil got a gleaming review from one of
the biggest value investors in history
warren buffett but a 15 book is hardly a
strain on most people's finances a
thousand dollar course on the other hand
actually could be so let's talk about
course sales this is where lots of fake
gurus start making real money and it's
also where things start to get predatory
if a book promises to reveal some secret
truth about success and it doesn't so
what you're out 15 bucks but if you
spend thousands of dollars with the
expectation that a particular course
would help you transition careers and
it's filled with a bunch of nonsense now
you have a problem so it's easy to look
at anyone who's selling courses online
and instantly label them a fake guru but
i think this is a mistake i've
personally had great experiences with
many online courses ranging from
completely free to thousands of dollars
i'll give an example a few years i was
getting really interested in motion
graphics and wanted to learn a new
program called houdini the software is
notorious for having a steep learning
curve and i was struggling to make
progress by myself so i paid around 400
for an online class called stop being
afraid of houdini the class was taught
by an experienced houdini artist and
after watching the lectures everything
really clicked for me i didn't become an
expert overnight but i learned enough to
get comfortable the key here is that the
promise of the course was extremely
narrow the instructor was only focused
on teaching you the basics of this
particular software and made no claims
about what you could do with those
skills once you had them he never said
you'll be able to work on the next
marvel movie or this will change your
life forever online courses are actually
one of the most powerful ways to learn
new skills in my experience and some
courses really take a lot of money to
produce truly knowledgeable people could
spend their time making money applying
those skills so you can't write them off
just because they're charging for
courses but there's one thing that
always seems like a major red flag paid
advertising remember that viral video
tai lopez paid to promote all over
youtube back in the day here in my
garage it always seems suspicious when
someone is paying money out of their own
pocket just to give you advice it just
doesn't add up these ads clearly cost a
lot of money to run so they must have a
plan to make a profit in the future and
that's certainly the way it works for
most fake gurus they blast ads out
across social media and then slowly push
potential clients through a funnel to
get them to spend more and more money it
might start with a semi-affordable
online course but then quickly progress
to more expensive mastermind sessions
and in-person conferences but as
ridiculous as that tai lopez video is
the crazy part to me is that what he's
actually saying is completely reasonable
at the time his pitch was basically to
encourage people to read more books
about business and he would make money
off of these ads by selling people a
book club where they would receive a box
of books in the mail every month even
though tai basically became the poster
boy of the fake guru phenomenon the
importance of reading really can't be
understated warren buffett has been a
voracious reader for decades but it was
perhaps marc andreessen who put it best
when he said there are thousands of
years of history in which lots and lots
of very smart people worked very hard
and ran all types of experiments on how
to create new businesses invent new
technology new ways to manage etc they
ran these experiments throughout their
lives at some point someone put these
lessons down in a book for very little
money and a few hours of your time you
can learn from someone's accumulated
experience there's so much more to learn
from the past than we often realize you
could productively spend your time
reading experiences of great people who
have come before you and learn every
single time but even though marc
andreessen might be saying something
similar to tai lopez he's not paying to
promote this concept but there's another
billionaire who does run ads ray dalio
the founder of bridgewater dalio has
published two massively successful books
full of advice and they've earned broad
acclaim the weird thing is that his team
will actually pay to promote his ideas
on facebook so what's going on well i
think rey genuinely believes that his
ideas are worth spreading so he's okay
with paying to promote his books online
there is another possibility though
these books serve as great recruitment
tools for the hedge fund he founded at
the end of the day a business is only
successful if talented people choose to
work there and rey's books certainly put
bridgewater on the map as a desirable
workplace so if we can't immediately
discard information from people who run
ads promoting their content how can we
reliably draw the line between fake
gurus and valuable teachers in order to
answer this question i asked two
youtubers who have studied fake gurus
over the past few years james johnny and
coffeezilla interestingly they both said
essentially the same thing it comes down
to false advertising and predatory
marketing the hallmark of a fake guru is
someone who claims to be able to
completely change your life help you get
healthy in just a few weeks or make you
a millionaire overnight these promises
are impossible to make good on even for
the best business leaders in the world
but these fake gurus have no problem
over promising and under delivering
because they know that there are always
more potential customers just around the
corner at least until coffeezilla makes
a video exposing them so now that we
have a solid framework for analyzing
fake gurus let's take a look at graham
steffen graham has been remarkably
successful on youtube and clearly has a
rabid fanbase who listened to everything
he says he easily could step over the
line and become a fake guru but has he
well in terms of advice he's extremely
conservative in his recommendations he's
always citing sources and recommending
tried and true investment strategies
he's never pumping sketchy crypto
projects and his constant
recommendations to buy etfs have
actually become a bit of a meme but what
about courses graham does sell online
courses but they're pretty reasonably
priced at around 400
and most importantly they are narrowly
targeted at teaching very specific
skills mainly youtube video production
and real estate sales which are areas
where graham has clear experience if he
was constantly dropping new classes
about topics that he had no experience
in that could quickly become predatory
but he doesn't so graham clearly isn't a
fake guru but youtube is still a messy
place filled with disinformation and
predatory marketing so stay safe out
there and if you want to learn some
business advice from the investors
behind coinbase airbnb doordash and many
more companies just watch my video about
y combinator next thanks for watching